Albert Woodfox
had four decades
in solitary confinement.
He was imprisoned here in
Angola State Penitentiary
for most of his life.
But it was an incident
a year after his arrival
in Angola that would change
the course of Albert's life.
A prison guard was
found murdered.
Albert believes he
and two other inmates
were framed because
of their affiliation
with the Black Panthers.
They became known
as the Angola Three.
Well, the Angola Three
consists of myself,
Herman Wallace, who
passed away in 2013,
and Robert Hillary King.
We, you know, joined
the Black Panther Party
while I was still in prison.
We became politically active.
We campaigned and
waged various protests
against institutional racism,
sexual slavery, brutality
and death by security staff
and prisoners upon one another
as a result of them,
you know, having
a low level of consciousness
as to what was going on.
On his 69th birthday,
after 43 years and 10 months
in solitary, Albert Woodfox
became the last of the Angola
Three to be released.
Albert's body finally
followed his mind to freedom.
I have four beautiful
great-grandkids now,
and I would like them to be
judged on their abilities,
you know, not their ethnicity
or the color or the skin or hair
textures or physical features.
You know, I would not want
them 10, 15, 20 years from now
to be fighting the
same battles that I've
been fighting most of my life.